round eight of the London chest pasta  the last stop on the grand chest tour  with the end of the tournament in sight  the best chess players in the world came  into the penultimate round looking to  gain a critical point to jump up the  leaderboard five-time world champion  Vishwanath on-on-on threw down the  gauntlet with a fantastic novelty and  it's another former champ listening  topalov who cracked under the pressure  and lost yet again to continue to have  one of the worst performances of his  career but the story of the round was  the coronation of Wesley so who  brilliantly neutralized the preparation  of compatriot Fabiano Khurana even the  ecstatic American is the clear winner of  the 2016 grand chest tour it's time to  determine who will win the London just  classic final round action for all the  marbles starts right now  [Music]